Delhi, located in North India, is the national
capital city of the country and has a metro
population of around twenty two million residents.
From the ancient congested alleys of Old Deli
to the wide tree lined boulevards of New Delhi,
it's a city that's overflowing with diversity
and opportunity.
With records that dates back to the 6th century
BC, Delhi is loaded with history, art, culture,
and religion.
No matter what you choose to do, you can be
certain it will be an adventure!
Now let's get started with these 21 things
to do in Delhi.
Number one is the Bahai Lotus Temple.
Which is one of the most popular and famous
destinations to visit.
It's made from marble, in the shape of a lotus
flower, and kind of representing a variety
of different religions.
They don't allow shoes in the temple, but
it's free to deposit your shoes in the cloakroom.
Number two is the Hare Krishna ISKCON temple.
Right now I'm at the Sri Sri Radha Parthasarathi
Mandir which is more popularly known as ISKCON.
Oh hello, how are you, I'm fine.
Are you at school?
Number three is Kalkaji Mandir, one of the
most famous Hindu Temples in the city.
Number four is Jama Masjid, the most significant
mosque in Old Delhi.
The Jama Masjid, which is the largest Muslim
mosque, here in, I think in all of India actually.
Right in the most hectic area of Delhi, known
as Chandni Chowk and the Chawri Bazar.
I am at Akshardham Temple complex in Delhi
India.
They do not allow any photography, or even
any electronics, or even any bags to go inside
the temple and the complex, but luckily they
have a really nice cloakroom where you can
leave all your stuff for free, and it's safe.
It's absolutely mind blowing, the detail is
stunning to say the least.
It's something you have to see when you're
in Delhi.
Number six is Gurdwara Bangla Sahib Sikh Temple.
I think it's the largest Sikh temple in Delhi,
and of course, you need to cover your head
before you enter, and also remove your shoes.
Number seven is the Laxmi Narayan Mandir - a
Hindu temple that was inaugurated by Mahatma
Gandhi.
It's one of the most famous Hindu temples
here in Delhi, India.
Now they don't allow any photography inside
so you actually have leave your shoes and
your camera is a secure like tourist room,
but this is another temple that you should
visit when you visit Delhi.
Number eight is the Hauz Khas historical complex.
So it's actually turned into kind of a park,
but there's ruins all around, there's a couple
of tombs also.
It once functioned sort of as a water complex,
so you can just sort of walk around this area
leisurely browse around this area.
Check out the ruins, the lake down below and
you can even have a picnic here and relax
if you'd like.
Number nine is Delhi's impressive Lodi Gardens.
I'm at the entrance of the Lodi Garden in
Delhi, and this is a big, very nicely maintained
park but at the same time it's a historical
attraction.
So within the park you can sort of walk around,
check out some of the tombs, and some of the
ancient structures around this park.
It's just like any other central park, but
in Delhi within the grass and trees are ancient
thousand year old tombs and monuments.
Number ten is the famous India Gate and its
quite similar to the Arc de triumph in Paris,
but it's like a victory gate commemorating
India.
Two rupees, no thank you.
Number eleven is the astronomy complex of
Jantar Mantar.
There's thirteen different astronomy instruments,
it's almost like a playground over here, but
you can walk around and check out the different
instruments.
Number twelve, one of the iconic landmarks
of Delhi, is Qutub Minar.
I think it's the tallest minaret in India,
and I think it measures about seventy three
meters in height, built in eleven ninety three,
this is an ancient site, and it's still in
fabulous condition.
It's really tall, and it's quite a site to
visit when you come to Delhi.
Flocks of birds flying from pillar to pillar
made the experience even more gorgeous.
Number thirteen is Humayun’s Tomb, a Mughal
masterpiece.
And this is one of the three UNESCO World
Heritage sites in Delhi.
It looks very well preserved but at the same
time they are doing some renovation as you
can see some scaffolding at the top of the
tomb there.
Number fourteen is the Tomb of Safdarjung.
This one is a little less maintained than
some of the other places I've been, but nevertheless
it's still an amazing attraction.
So it's just a five minute walk from the Jor
Bagh metro station to get here.
Number fifteen is Raj Ghat, a memorial park
dedicated to Mahatma Gandhi.
At the Mahatma Gandhi memorial.
Number sixteen is Delhi's Red Fort.
Which is another one of Delhi's UNESCO World
Heritage sites, and it's a big complex you
can walk around, see a number of different
monuments, it's like an entire walled in city,
and to be honest it sort of almost looks like
a college campus right now, but it's a nice
grounds to walk around and check out these
amazing historical sites.
Number seventeen is the chaotic business area
of Chandni Chowk and Chawri Bazar.
I am in Delhi India, Old Delhi at Chandni
Chowk and this is one of the most busy business
and shopping districts in the old city, always
entertaining, always busy.
There's basically anything you could ever
want to buy, as well as lots of famous restaurants,
and lots of food to eat.
So Chandni Chowk, this is Old Delhi, India.
While walking around Chandni Chowk, you can
visit the Sikh Temple, and just get lost in
the market alleys.
You'll also find incredible food like jalebis
and parathas in the area.
Now one of the best ways to get around Chandni
Chowk in Delhi is by cycle rickshaw, and these
guys can go anywhere, and it's amazing actually
the places they can fit and things they can
get through and the busyness.
wow.
But it's definitely always an exciting ride.
Number eighteen is Dilli Haat, a handicraft
market and village.
I'm at the Dilli Haat which is kind of a central
handicraft market here in Delhi, set up by
the tourism authority.
Now it costs twenty rupees entrance fee, but
it's a fantastic place to purchase handicrafts
from around the entire country.
There's also different canteens, where you
can sample cuisine from around the entire
country, so that is what I'm looking forward
to most actually.
Number nineteen is Paharganj, also known as
the main bazaar.
And this is kind of the backpacker area, there's
lots of budget guest houses and hostels as
well as a lot of restaurants and shopping
all around this street.
And it's just a short walk from New Delhi
train station railway station, so this is
called the main bazar area.
Number twenty is the modern business district
of Connaught Place.
This is Connaught Place, known more locally
just as CP.
Full of all kinds of shopping, restaurants,
a lot of street vendors as well, but basically
anything you could want is available somewhere
within this gigantic roundabout, and there's
kind of like a series of roundabouts as well,
and then with a park in the middle, and also
an underground shopping center.
CP is such a huge area that it's honestly
a little confusing, so be sure to decide where
you want to go and bring a map.
Be careful of the crazy street crossings and
the many touts in the area.
Number twenty one is Delhi street food.
Stopping on the side of a road for a bowl
of chole, a rich chickpea curry, and a piping
hot fresh chapati is one of the joys of visiting
Delhi.
There are also numerous other tasty treats
to grab on the go while exploring.
It’s up to you now to visit Delhi and experience
this diverse and interesting land that will
keep you on the edge of your seat occasionally,
but will keep amazed time after time again.
Thank you very much for watching this video.
And also I'm excited, I've just launched by
Delhi travel guide, so if you click that cover
right over there, you can go check it out,
be sure to grab a copy, it includes all sort
of what to do, what to see, and of course,
where and what to eat in Delhi.
So go check that out, and other than that,
have a great day, see you soon.